attacks from russian forces as ground
troops try to breach its borders and the
southern port of odessa was hit for the
first time by shelling in the early
hours of this morning but for many towns
and cities here they are under regular
bombardment with whole buildings
flattened and thousands of civilian
deaths today new video has emerged from
her son the first place to be taken by
the russian military which shows russian
troops firing at protesters
well in the city of harkeef hospitals
are struggling under the pressures of
war
a correspondent john sparks reports now
from there
the streets of harkev have been
abandoned by the majority of those who
live here
half a million have fled this city
their prized possessions in a bag
and their cars discarded at the station
those who remain hide in the shadows in
the dark or the deep underground
more than a dozen metro stations have
been turned into shelters
these battered looking train carriages
redeployed as home how long have you
been living here uh three or three three
weeks how do you feel about it so first
we are when we hear something blow up
we're around here but now we're like
what was that oh shooting
the experience is a trial for a new
mother called natalia
she gave birth to her son two days after
the invasion began
the hospital then sent her here
[Music]
car on platform 2 with a cot and clothes
provided by volunteers
natalia says life will never be the same
again
residents who remain will try to endure
but some are no longer able the city
morgue receives 50 to 100 bodies a day
caused by the war and by natural causes
but they don't have room to examine them
here and they don't have the staff to
bury them
[Music]
when a russian missile struck this
institute the entire neighborhood was
damaged in the blast
85 year old stella ivanovna told us she
hung onto the door frame in the hope
she'd survive what was it like when
the bombing happened when the missile
hit
[Music]
that video
one of her neighbors called deanna was
not so fortunate
she was caught in the explosion glass
from the windows puncturing her face
her doctor at harkeev's main hospital
said there's a fine line between life
and death
next door we found four men fighting for
their lives
one hit by shrapnel another blown up by
a mine
sergey is an opera singer turned
volunteer who was shot seven times as he
tried to evacuate local residents
and he celebrated with an old italian
song of resistance
[Music]
death and displacement have come to
everybody's doorstep but there are many
here who are determined to hold on john
sparks sky news harkev
well the capital kiev has not been taken
by russian forces but does continue to
be hit by a barrage of attacks well this
was the moment that russian forces hit a
shopping center near the center of kiev
killing at least eight people these
pictures released by the russian
military ministry of defense who claimed
that the images show ukrainian military
vehicles at the shopping mall before the
strike the attack happened late on
sunday night destroying the mall and
shattering the windows of every
neighboring high rise building
wiscais special correspondent alex
crawford traveled to the small town of
lutich north of kiev the last community
before the front line and russian held
territory from there she sent this
report
the capitals northern suburbs are under
attack the skyline's increasingly
clouded after rocket strikes
the russian military is trying to push
closer into the city but they've got to
get through three small communities in
between
we're rushed through checkpoints the
shells land here without warning causing
fires which rip through this forested
area
and in lootish they know they're the
ones now holding the line against the
russians so they're digging trenches
and bolstering their positions
the community's already been hit several
times
the attacks have left yet more people
without homes
and workplaces and businesses have been
left shattered
but the main supermarket is still
operating despite being shelled earlier
the staff are just wiping down their
supplies and carrying on regardless
we even know how to protect ourselves if
something is incoming she says we lie
down and cover our heads
a lot of the fridges and storage areas
are damaged the constant volley of
attacks has seen half the town empty the
other half can't understand why this is
they've happening our houses our schools
our shops she said they're hurting us
too much for what please someone explain
nadia shows us the crater that's been
left in her back garden parts of the
rocket still visible
god loves me she says i can't believe
i'm alive
inside her house she shows us how almost
every room is affected with the ceiling
down and windows shattered
she lives alone with her 81 year old
mother who's clearly unsettled
granny was born during the second world
war nadia explains about her mother now
she has to survive another
her mother and her have been here all
their lives leaving is inconceivable
and for those who've lived through this
all before the war has awful echoes
her daughter interrupts children are
dying women are dying she says
this isn't just war this is destroying
this is genocide of the people they're
just killing us to eliminate us they
want to remove us from the surface of
the land
so they see their defense of these
northern suburbs as critical
and the sounds of russians nearby seems
constant whilst we're here
they're nazis he says
and there's another attack
he waits to hear if it's landing close
by
he was a swimming coach a few weeks ago
now everyone here is a bombing expert
the man taking us into their bunker was
a tv producer now part of the army
keeping the foreign troops outside the
capital how will they be able to get
inside keith do you think
[Music]
no they cannot capture keep he says they
can try to surround it but if they try
to enter they'll face very heavy
resistance
and helping them is leon from chichester
who came to keeve on his motorbike and
went straight to the front line i
thought to myself
how could i not do something about this
how can i not go out there and help
especially seeing the war crimes being
committed on civilian populations i just
thought that i can't can't sit by and
let this happen
he's standing shoulder to shoulder with
the ukrainian volunteers helping out as
a medic and now defending kiev
they've got mannequins at the entrance
of lutish to try to confuse any russian
snipers the residents inside here know
this could be a long drawn out and
bloody war alex crawford sky news in the
northern outskirts of kiev
well the u.s ambassador was summoned by
russia's foreign ministry today after
what they called unacceptable comments
by u.s president joe biden about
russia's vladimir putin let's bring in
sky's martha kelner who joins us now
live from washington dc and in fact joe
biden has just been speaking to
some world leaders martha ahead of his
visit to europe this week
he certainly has i know he had a
conversation that we understand that we
understand lasted just under an hour
with boris johnson and also with the
leaders of germany france and italy
we're just getting through some details
in the last couple of minutes about what
exactly they discussed on that call
we're told that they spoke about serious
concerns about russia's brutal tactics
in ukraine including its tactics on
submitting its attacks apologies on
civilians
we're also told that those leaders
underscored their continued support for
ukraine including by providing security
assistance to the brave ukrainians who
are defending their country the leaders
were told also reviewed recent
diplomatic efforts in support of
ukraine's effort to reach a ceasefire so
no real developments to grasp hold of
there but this conversation between
those world leaders was a preamble to
president biden's trip to europe and
later on this week that's part of a
wider diplomatic push to maintain this
coordinated response by the us and
allies to russia's aggression and i
guess ultimately however unlikely it may
seem at the moment to try and find a
diplomatic solution to this crisis the
trip to europe is the first president
biden has made since the invasion into
ukraine by russia more than three weeks
ago
it's fair to say that this is a critical
test for his presidency we had the
ukrainian president vladimir zelinski um
commenting to congress last week urging
president biden to be a leader of the
world and a leader of peace the question
is
what if anything can be done
diplomatically and i guess perhaps the
more pertinent question is what is the
us what are the us and allies willing to
do to stop vladimir putin
and on that note the the first and
perhaps the most important engagement in
president biden's diary in europe is an
emergency nato meeting on thursday and
we know there's a divergence of opinion
within nato on how to deal with russian
aggression we expect poland to use that
emergency meeting of nato to formally
put forward
their proposal for an international
peacekeeping mission in ukraine which
would involve nato boots on the ground
poland also wants to send fighter jets
these russian-made
fighter jets into ukraine something the
us has resisted so far because they
believe doing that might be seen as an
escalatory action to vladimir putin they
fear that could provoke a wider conflict
so we expect a divergence of opinion on
that in this nato meeting later this
week but certainly a critical test for
president biden on the world stage
martha they're in washington thank you
very much indeed well i'm joined now by
david miliband former foreign secretary
of course and now president and ceo of
the international rescue committee who
is in new york for us good to see you
we'll come on to diplomatic efforts in
just a moment but first of all i want to
get your reaction uh to what we're
seeing here the escalating horrors of
war the brutal tactics as we just heard
there they're from uh biden schultz
macron and johnson you know bombardment
siege civilian deaths um
what do you think we're witnessing here
thanks very much and i think that people
need to understand the scale
of the bombardment the pulverization
campaign that's going on and the human
as well as the military consequences
you've been covering the fact that there
are three million refugees who've
crossed from ukraine into europe those
are women and children in the main
because the men are obviously
conscripted but inside ukraine you've
got 6 million people seven million maybe
who are on the move inside the country
and you've got 12 million people
to varying degrees trapped in towns and
cities that are under bombardment i've
been in touch with the people overseeing
our teams international rescue committee
teams today
and the needs are very very clear there
are obviously people being killed and
wounded there are water supplies being
cut
there are enormous issues around health
water and sanitation the economy is
obviously collapsed and so you've got an
absolutely massive humanitarian
situation inside the country while the
fighting is still going on and that's
why the calls for ceasefires for pauses
are so important but obviously it also
speaks to the fact that this ukrainian
resistance to the invasion has been much
stronger
than the russian
invaders expected
well listening to your figures then um
you've got about 10 million displaced
either inside or outside the country
plus the 12 million 22 million that's
half the population being affected by
this it's you know we're looking at
unprecedented levels here aren't we the
question is now i suppose what will stop
president putin
well you're absolutely right to stress
that this is certainly unprecedented in
europe since the second world war
there are 44 million
citizens of ukraine so your 22 million
figure is obviously half of the
population just by way of comparison the
syrian population was about 23 million
11 years ago and 6 million
are refugees outside the country and 8
million are internally displaced so this
european catastrophe is very much on a
scale with the worst that we've seen
since the second world war i think that
there are two aspects to an answer of
your question about what's going to stop
the invasion they're related as well the
first is clearly the russian forces the
military forces have to varying degrees
being stopped in different parts of the
country and most of the military
analysts are now saying that
a full-scale
onslaught on kiev may be
imminent
but the takeover of kiev is not imminent
and actually it's mario paul
in the south of the country that's been
sustaining the the most siege-like
tactics other towns and cities may be
getting a pummelling but they're not yet
besieged at the second thing that may
stop this is obviously pressure either
from within or without
on
president putin and this takes me away
from the humanitarian side of my job to
i suppose the diplomatic work i used to
do but obviously there's there's
politics involved inside russia there's
politics internationally and the kind of
unity that president biden is drumming
up through the way in which he's engaged
across the atlantic but also
internationally i think has helped to
not just sustain the ukrainian
government and its people but also make
clear this is a defining moment globally
because so much of the impunity that
we're seeing inside ukraine has been
seen elsewhere
over the last decade
yes certainly sanctions are pulled back
on russian oil from many nations banking
systems too but this is a slow burn
isn't it and this is you know this is
urgent this
everything around us right now the
citizens dying being maimed and
suffering all the time so how do you
tackle an autocrat like that when people
are not not even allowed to speak out or
protest in the street there's no
mechanism to overthrow somebody
it's certainly urgent but there isn't a
quick fix i mean this has been at least
a decade
in the making you've covered before on
sky news the 2014
invasion of crimea which in a way was a
taster for what has happened
here what's the way that this gets
beaten back this impunity i think
obviously unity
among the rest of the world is very very
important it's not yet unanimous but
only four countries supported russia in
the general assembly uh two weeks ago
the general assembly of the united
nations secondly i think very
importantly this is obviously a
ukrainian
fight
it's a fight that people are making for
their own homeland
and that's something that can have
outside support but in the end it has to
be for the ukrainians to determine their
own future that is the principle
at stake
here and that's the role the supportive
role that's been played by outsiders i
think the third thing that i would want
to emphasize
is that trying to sustain life and limb
for ukrainian civilians is also part of
this
fight it's different from the military
but the efforts that are being made to
make sure that water and sanitation
systems survive the health needs are met
that's part of this effort to make sure
that this unprovoked act of aggression
doesn't win out
and just very very quickly if you don't
mind to bring you back to um the
humanitarian sphere we've talked about
refugees but you know clearly this is
the breadbasket of europe in many
respects isn't it the ukrainians are
desperate to plant their crops but this
really does have implications too for
for global food prices and and feeding
parts of the world
yes you're absolutely right that
there's going to be inflationary impact
in the uk or the us obviously but that's
measured in percentage points in other
parts of the world that are dependent on
the world food program defendant on that
bread basket you refer to it's much more
dire consequences and this really is not
just a geopolitical turning point it's
also a global turning point when it
comes to survival for too many people
well david miliband we appreciate your
time there joining us from new york uh
president and ceo of the international
rescue committee hopefully speak again
soon
we'll stay with us coming up in this
special program on the wall in ukraine
uh the residents of odessa clearing up
after a night of heavy shelling
[Music]
ukrainian government is confirming that
they are now engaged with russian
soldiers air raid sirens fill the
airways in the distance artillery rains
down it feels very close to the center
of
there's one they found this devastation
to their apartment
lots of people live here quite a few of
the windows of the houses have been
blown out by the blast
and it feels that it's changing each day
[Music]
look at that sheet of flakes and it's
moving this way
and over there is dover we track the
changes happening to our world right now
i think it's a procession of the taliban
there they are right here would you as
prime minister be able to look them in
the face let's have a look at both of
those two things i just want to say
thank you for having the courage to
speak to us we do genuinely believe in
what we do to show the truth
i thought there was an astonishing story
there
mr trump james james matthews from sky
news hey james
[Music]
i'm james matthews and i'm skye's
scotland correspondent
[Music]
[Music]
well residents around the country who
have not been able to flee their homes
are now dealing with the aftermath of
shelling since the start of russia's
invasion of ukraine it's been feared
that the port of odessa could be the
next city to fall and people there have
certainly been preparing for that attack
well in the early hours of this morning
the inevitable happened when strikes hit
the city damaging homes
our correspondent nick martin reports
now from odessa
the shells hit in the early morning
an air raid siren had warned residents
to take shelter otherwise this could
have been much worse
is what the ground looks like when a
shell smashes into it causing damage to
windows and walls of this apartment
block
because we are the worry because we are
living near of the coast on the border
of the sea
so
i think all people who has no any way to
go somewhere who stay here
they are
[Music]
praying
another shell struck this house luckily
the owners were hiding in a nearby
garage at the time
these apartments are just on the
seafront here and in the early hours of
this morning residents said they heard
loud bangs this is where one of the
shells landed and after the explosion it
would have sent shrapnel flying towards
this building you can see all the little
marks in the masonry where it struck and
the damage to the glass that was caused
we walked further down towards the coast
and come across iriana and alexander
they've lived here for two years but
moved to a safer place just a few weeks
ago
and it's a good job they did
because a shell went straight through
the front of their home
i would love that putin and his
propaganda spreaders when they are
caught before a trial to be carried in a
cage like an animal throughout the
country to show him what he and his
liars did to ukraine
the only feeling i have is gratitude
that everyone's alive and everyone's
here what can i do
those in mariopol are in much worse
conditions
the ukrainian military say this is the
first time that shells from russian navy
warships in the black sea have struck
odessa
the military here know that the war is
coming to them and believe the russians
are testing their defenses and their
resolve
numbers there are two important issues
firstly it is a demonstration of
firepower and psychological pressure and
secondly they are trying to carry out
reconnaissance and find out the
locations of our air and coastal
defenses
odessa has been expecting an attack of
some kind for weeks now this could be a
warning sign that more strikes are
likely nick martin sky news odessa
we'll stay with us coming up on the
special programme on the war in ukraine
we will have the very latest on the
situation for those fleeing the fighting
here
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to this special programme
on the war in ukraine and russian troops
have opened fire as ukrainians protested
against the invasion in the southern
city of herson well let's find out more
sky sally lockwood who's also in levi
joins me now live and her son sally the
first city to fall
people have been protesting there almost
daily not the first time shots have been
fired but certainly it looks like
russian forces are starting to get very
frustrated
yes that's right anna it was rather
shocking when that footage uh emerged
this afternoon her son as you say that
southern city
was taken by russian forces around the
second of march so quite a while ago but
very brave people have been taking to
the streets there almost on a daily
basis to protest their presence against
what they deem to be an occupation of
their city by russian forces and today
that footage emerged of them being fired
at peaceful protesters being fired at in
her son we believe it was smoke grenades
that were thrown at them initially
but then a military expert who we asked
to examine the footage said that they
can hear machine gun fire
following that now there is mounting
evidence here in ukraine that civilians
are being targeted by russian forces
that's not the only concerning report
that we've had today in the southeastern
region of zaparisha where so many people
are fleeing to from mario paul
a convoy of buses taking
civilians to a humanitarian corridor to
evacuate them was shot upon the governor
of zaparisha saying that four children
were injured
in that attack and have been taken to
hospital i spoke to a young woman who
had escaped mario pole in the last few
days she's actually fled to zaparisha
but still feels uh close enough to marry
a pole to be in danger
and on top of that a ukrainian
politician today also claimed
that russian forces were shooting people
shooting civilians at point-blank range
uh in the capital kiev uh and indeed a
new uh curfew has come into place in the
capital tonight uh from eight o'clock
around an hour and a half ago for 36
hours until wednesday morning because
they are
expecting an onslaught in the next
couple of days
sally live there and live thank you
well from leading normal lives one day
to taking up arms the next millions of
people in ukraine have had their lives
turned upside down since the start of
the conflict a few weeks ago but paul
nylon from ireland has lived in ukraine
for 19 years and has already been
defending his adopted home by keeping
watch over his residential area with a
security team and i'm pleased to say
that paul joins me now so paul what's
happened to you then and where have you
decided to go
uh good evening i'm uh temporarily in
the west of ukraine i'm in love at the
moment um
i had to come out here for business
reasons and also decided to
combine it with a personal trip as well
um and uh i'm grateful for having this
time out of kiev to be honest to be able
to recharge my batteries but i'll be
going back uh this weekend kiev is my
home and uh that's where i intend to be
and
um we'll we'll see what happens next
we'll see what unfolds next
well indeed so i mean you know the
russians have been held back certainly
the bombardment continues it must be a
difficult place to live right now
it's difficult everywhere in the in the
country i just was waiting to come on
now i was watching your reports there
from odessa and uh and from here son um
you know talking about uh
civilians being
shot at a point-blank range by the
russian occupying forces in in various
different cities um there was a report
three or four days ago
uh of a group of people who were lined
up to purchase bread um and uh a
group of russian military uh passed this
this line outside this store and opened
fire on them killing ten people uh it's
difficult everywhere across the country
even here in la vie which is in the the
far west of the country we've had four
air raid sirens uh that have gone off
today the first one was at about four
o'clock this morning um in recent days
there have been missile strikes on the
airport on the outskirts of this city
as well
and
overnight in in kiev a very very large
and almost brand new shopping center was
completely destroyed by a ballistic
missile there as well um and uh yeah
it's
it's tragic to see this happening
because because ukraine is a is a
perfectly peaceful country and ukraine
has done absolutely nothing to provoke
this if you go back and look at russia's
initial attempts to justify what they
were doing you know one of the things
that they said was their goal was to
denazify ukraine ukraine isn't a country
of
extremist views or where you know
extremists of any
kind of description are harbored or or
even tolerated it it's a it's a
ludicrous basis it's a it's a totally
untrue basis for this war
and for someone like you who saw
something in this land to choose to make
it your home
how did how much does it paint you to
witness what we're seeing now
i i i made ukraine my home uh or ukraine
made me make it my home uh let's say i
i've been here for such a long time and
i've participated in momentous events in
the history of this country when there
have been revolutions on the maidan
square in the center of kiev i was there
too and
of course it pains me uh to see what's
happening across the country especially
um it pains me that friends of mine um
colleagues of mine are now um you know
they have taken up arms uh many of the
people i work with the veterans and so
they've taken arms again and gone back
to defend their country but but others
who i know are are out there and they're
fighting against this invasion and um
you know i i i it's going to be an
incredibly sad uh moment for me if i
find out that i've i've lost anyone uh
particularly close to me but
that that's going to be i i suspect the
effects of this war um all of us who are
in ukraine are going to be touched by
this
on one level or another and the the
collective uh emotional crisis that the
country is going for is some going
through is something that we will all be
feeling the the the scars from and
feeling the brunt of for many years to
come unfortunately
yes and i'm afraid that's a sentiment
we've heard expressed quite often people
waiting to see if they've heard
of somebody who has been injured or lost
their life um we spoke last week to
someone from hakeef who uh you know an
ethnically russian-speaking area um who
said this is making everybody a
ukrainian nationalist you know has this
brought the country together in a way
that some people thought was not
possible
uh the the the current escalation of the
war has done that yes uh that's true but
uh the war in actual fact has been
ongoing in ukraine since 2014 when
russia first illegally annexed crimea
and then invaded the
the donbass region in the the east of
the country as well so you know having
to uh send our
our classmates our neighbors our friends
our brothers um to go and defend those
portions of ukraine as well that has
already been united in the the country
and you know to talk about people as uh
russian speakers or or ukrainian
speakers it it really isn't something
that the language question isn't
something that has ever divided ukraine
not in
my many years of experience here in this
country no nobody has ever
really uh
bothered about another person's language
choice we everybody pretty much is
bilingual everybody chooses which
language they're most comfortable with
and and most people speak speak both and
you know a hardcurve yes uh
predominantly it's a russian-speaking
city but um they are patriots of ukraine
at the same time and and
kiev is a perfect example um
of
one of the the worst affected cities in
this war it's very very close to the
russian border so it's one of the first
places
got to
i do apologize i'm going to have to
i apologize for uh for for butting in
there um i do i do you have lots of
other people to talk to so i do
apologize but uh good luck if you do
head back into the capital we wish you
the very best of luck paul nyland there
who has made ukraine his home well let's
uh go straight to more on the help
that's being offered to those fleeing
the conflict with envert solomon
chief executive of the refugee council
who is in north london for us good to
have you on as well
so more than 10 million people displaced
internally or externally david miliband
uh former foreign secretary told us that
12 million people are trapped that is
half the nation affected by this what do
you think about what we're seeing here
i mean it's extraordinary it's a refugee
crisis on a scale that we haven't seen
in europe for decades since the second
world war and more than three million
people three and a half million now are
actually refugees and of those nearly
1.5 million a children that's a child
that's been become a refugee almost for
every second that this war has been
taking place it's unimaginable uh the
scale of the human tragedy and suffering
and the numbers affected are
are really mind-blowing if you think
about it and important to remember that
these are mainly women and children many
of whom are very vulnerable we've heard
stories of of teenagers being told to
just travel by themselves out of ukraine
to find safety
some being told because they speak
english to find their own way to the uk
and it's really important
that all european nations and the uk do
everything possible to welcome
ukrainian refugees who seek sanctuary in
the uk and in europe
well indeed do you think the uk is doing
enough i have to say i've just had
um
well this statement actually from a
family friend of ours who's trying to
get his ukrainian wife her daughter and
granddaughter out of the country they
all live together in clemency just north
of dalit pro they've managed to get as
far as prague this is what they had to
said to us this evening i have to fill
in three online application forms in
english not ukrainian as a parliamentary
answer promised each several pages long
supported with various downloaded
scanned documents how many of these poor
refugees women and young children
in the maine have the capacity to do
that
have we still made it too complicated in
the uk
i think we probably have made it too
complicated and i think the fundamental
problem is and we've been pointing this
out to the government is the government
is trying to use a standard visa scheme
to respond to a humanitarian crisis and
using a visa scheme which in and of
itself is always very bureaucratic with
a number of hurdles for people to get
through a number of quite complex
forms to be completed is not the best
way necessarily to respond to a
humanitarian crisis and it is in stark
difference to countries
in the eu all the countries in eu france
spain germany italy etc who have simply
said come you don't need a visa come to
our countries and we will provide
sanctuary to you and i think the british
government needs to think about whether
it should be waiving visas now
to provide a much more simpler direct
frictionless route for people to get to
the uk as quickly as possible so you
don't have cases like the one you've
just talked about where people are
battling through complex forms and
complex bureaucracy that isn't good
enough as a response to a humanitarian
crisis
yes we've witnessed the uh the reaction
of people in poland it's it's quite
heartwarming i have to say the
generosity of spirit that you see on the
on the border but it's not easy for
people it's becoming clearer is it not
that this will not be a quick conflict
that is one issue the other of course is
that many of those neighboring nations
the towns and cities are beginning to
feel at capacity so what happens now
well that is when
western european nations the countries
such as
as ours the uk and the rest of the eu
needs to step up and there's a very
important principle here that nations
who
respond to refugee crisis need to share
the responsibility so it's not
acceptable if poland has over a million
heading for two million refugees and
other european nations have far fewer we
need to share
that responsibility and that means that
the uk
as well as germany france italy uh spain
and other countries sweden
step up and and does its parts and at
the moment we have far fewer refugees
from ukraine than any other european
country indeed ireland
has had more than applications more
accepted more applications today as i
understand it than the uk we need to
make sure that the process is quick that
it's rapid that we remove the
bureaucracy and that we enable every
single ukrainian that wants to reach
safety in the uk to come here to rebuild
their lives is able to do that and if
that means we need to rethink the visa
scheme and waive the visas for a period
of time the government must consider
doing that
well very good to have you on envert
solomon uh chief executive of the
refugee council thank you very much
indeed
well next to come here on sky new does
putin's war uh mean a return to the
soviet era repression we'll be
discussing that next
[Music]
i'm david blevins and i'm skye's senior
ireland correspondent
[Music]
i'm based in belfast the city
transformed by peace but still
struggling with its past
politically the two sides are as far
apart as ever and it's over that
question of who has sovereignty in
northern ireland
the very issue that's been the source of
tension here for generations
it takes 60 minutes to cross the irish
sea it took the british monarchy a
century
i've spent 25 years reporting the
journey from conflict to peace
the political parties of northern
ireland have reached agreement
we help you understand the world with us
today
we have reached an agreement with the
conservative party on support for
government in parliament
we already know what the government gets
out of this deal what exactly does the
dup get out of it well 1.5 billion
pounds
welcome to winterfell it's an iconic
location in this globally acclaimed
drama
ophelia was the most powerful hurricane
this far east in the atlantic on record
you can't live in a place like this and
not appreciate the environment
it was everything that a journalist
might want in a story a story that you'd
be proud to have filmed
that they didn't want journalists to see
the real story
it was very tiring it was very sad it
was very scary at times
but you have to keep going
look at that
you don't want to lecture people but you
do have to give them a fact
well secret police mass execution and
repression the soviet union has a dark
history with many aspects still shrouded
in secrecy today but with putin's
invasion of ukraine and an
ever-tightening grip on dissenting
voices at home in russia could we be
seeing a return to soviet-era tyranny
well let's get more on that now with
sergey redchenko historian and professor
of international relations at cardiff
university good to see you
this this war has shocked the world has
it not and continues to shock with its
brutality um why invade and why the
aggression
well
it's it's very difficult to say what
went through putin's mind when he
ordered this invasion a lot of people in
moscow simply could not and still cannot
believe that he actually chose to invade
neighboring countries and that that that
that includes the what you would call a
policy elite you know the blob uh people
who normally advise the government a lot
of people who are simply in shock they
still do not understand whether putin is
simply driven by you know imperial
visions of 19th century russia what it
is that he's trying to do restore the
soviet union now this was unpredictable
for that very reason nobody thought that
he would do something like that so
aggressive so blatant incurring
massive international sanctions and yet
he did so you know what can we say well
now
i think a lot of russians still have not
recovered from the shock of listos who
who actually pay attention to these
things and who who are you know who are
critical thinkers
and to go back to the to the level of
aggression we're seeing i mean the
suggestion that russia has a brutalized
history by joseph stalin and it's kind
of you know it's there now you know are
we seeing putin return to to a
stalin-esque um mode of operandi if i
can put it like that no what what you
know we have now is aggression external
aggression and it's hardly surprising
that external aggression com comes with
tyranny domestically i mean russia has a
long history of tyranny um people
sometimes compare putin to stalin and
you know for many years i would say well
this is this comparison is is completely
irrelevant yes putin is an authoritarian
leader etc etc there there are some
political repressions in russia but
certainly not to the extent like in
stalin's days i mean we're talking about
hundreds of thousands of people who were
being killed in the soviet union back in
the day people were being sent to prison
camps to slave laborers i mean we still
do not have this in russia now i have to
be clear about this russia today is not
stalinist ussr but you know what's scary
is that russia is increasingly moving in
that direction and it's been moving so
fast that nobody can be sure where this
trajectory takes it next uh we've seen
in recent
days
in the next in the last couple of weeks
new laws being passed in russia that
make it punishable by up to 15 years in
prison to criticize this war now that
doesn't mean that everybody is going to
prison at the moment for 15 years people
15 000 people approximately have been
detained since war protests broke out in
moscow about uh uh where now more than
two weeks ago
and uh you know not they haven't been
sent to prison for 15-year terms a lot
of them are just facing fines but the
legal basis for repressions is there and
what we're seeing is russia steadily
moving in the direction and frankly i
can't you know i do not know that that
we have seen the end of this i think
where still russia is still waiting for
the worst
yes many people you know saying next
step the gulags after that law
excuse me that law was passed
it's a cold weather i do apologize
i spoke to a volunteer to do a pensioner
who said he remembered the cues for
butter in the soviet era and then very
calmly said that all autocracies lead to
war would you agree
autocracies lead to war that's you know
that's a well-known uh uh
idea i suppose because you know that's
just how the world has worked in the
20th century we have seen stalinist
tyranny and stalinist wars we have seen
hitler's tyranny in hitler's wars and
and that is the fear i think that is the
fear that putin has who has completely i
think lost contact with reality is now
returning this repressive mechanisms
that we have had in stalinist pass to
again reimpose the sort of draconian
measures in control on the russian
society today you see russia has never
really faced up to its history and those
stalinist crimes although people have
talked about them the crimes of the
1930s there have has never really been
a kind of a uh accounting for those
crimes i mean the the people who
committed mass you know executions have
have they've been called to account many
of them actually later retired and lived
out happy lives so russia has never
overcome its legacy of stalinism
unfortunately and we can see this
creeping back into the public discourse
and that is truly scary i think a lot of
russian intellectuals liberals who
who really hate putin's regime
with great passion as a lot of people in
moscow uh are
are absolutely terrified now but you
know one thing that also has to be kept
in mind there is actually considerable
public support for this war as well and
one day what you would call the masses
unfortunately we don't know how many
people support the war the problem is
that in the authoritarian context you
can no longer have proper statistical
surveys carried out people will not tell
you the truth you call them up as a
statistician or survey person said you
know do you support putin do you support
this war they will say yes just just to
be you know
sergey we're running out of time do you
apologize sergey retchenko from cardiff
thank you very much indeed
well we heard from paul and island that
this has brought
ukraine together and there's certainly a
massive volunteering effort those people
who can't fight at the front line have
definitely stepped up to do whatever
they can to help defend their country in
any way they can as i saw today at a
volunteering center making camouflage
nets for the front line
the war effort starts here it's a long
and slow process as you can see they use
anything they can get their hands on
donated old clothes new clothes
materials straight from manufacturers
you know sheets pillowcases coats even
ladies tights as well absolutely vital
to try and make a pattern that is
unreadable by anything in the air this
is also a library as well it's actually
reopened such as the demand victor is
one of those who's volunteered and why
do you think it's so important for for
someone like you to get involved like
this
i think it's also important not only
from the petrol point of view because
our soldiers need it it can save lives
it's like a
psychological treatment you know of a
prophylaxis that is you or you stay at
home doing nothing just watching the
drastic tragic news or you are coming
here you are
communicating with people mixing with
people who have share the same views as
you and also doing this monotonous work
you protect your mental health
victor thank you very much indeed well
let's see upstairs then how the nets end
up
well it's actually mid brown and dark
brown they're short of right now and
that is because we're coming out of
winter of course the colors will change
as the seasons do a protracted battle
perhaps but here they weave onto
fishing nets all of that material that's
been cut up downstairs and the idea is
that this is unreadable from the sky
from russian drones or aircraft very
hard to see if it's handmade a pattern
that could be read if it was
manufactured
they used to make about 20 25 of these
nets a day but some of the volunteers
have gone back to work it's as if
they've tried to go back to their normal
life and now it's about five of these
nets a day specifically requested by a
battalion
the colours that they need and they will
send them on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you